you're back welcome to our back and
vagina and julienne podcast the where am
i podcast yeah for the last couple weeks
it's been a little wild but we are back
and we are podcast in and we're actually
periscoping this podcast right now we're
periscoping with our periscope family
what's up guys we're waving to our
preschool this podcast is brought to you
by Squarespace
Squarespace calm has some of the best
templates for you to create your own
website on whatever that website might
be for your online shop your blog your
business go to Squarespace calm and
check it out you get 10% off when you
enter product code jayjay checkout Thank
You Squarespace Thank You Squarespace uh
we used to do this on all the podcast we
would have Ustream up we got to be what
we did instead of podcasts we would just
sit well that's how the podcast came to
be chat for hours yeah
but then yeah we had two laptops one
recording audio and one recording or one
on Ustream but now that periscope exists
there's no need for any of that floating
sculpt so periscope is here and we will
be um periodically referring to our
commenters and our friends hang out
thank you for hanging out guys on
periscope
um well Jenna and I both thought it was
a good idea to just kind of chill out
this podcast we had two relatively
serious podcasts in a row we talked
about Kanye and about Miley Cyrus so why
not have a nice not heavy podcast you
can mess up - yeah what happened the
technical depth we need a chill - out
yeah this is we also flew in and we got
in it but we got home at like 11:00
began yesterday yeah I don't even know
no we got home at 7:00 a.m. oh seven
eight I'm sorry no idea uh we arrived
Australia yeah so we are we flew in we
left Australia at nine eight nine
fifty-nine morning on Sunday and we
arrived at 7 a.m. on Sunday on Sunday in
LA so I told my dad dad he was like well
why don't you pick yourself up from the
airport um but yes we arrived at 7 a.m.
from an international flight yesterday
yeah what were your spell
and at nine o'clock what happened we
want some girls Oh killer tailwind like
zip tin there yeah that was wild like
when they were like jamming our
breakfast down our throats I don't think
that they expected us to land that early
oh well I appreciated that mmm
Julianne does I like breakfast but yeah
so we arrived at 7:00 and we got home
and we were just like fight the tired
like stay awake I was like Jenna don't
lay on the couch like that like turn
your body a little bit so you're more
uncomfortable like don't do that and
soon enough we both succumb so we we
took a little nap yeah
and I limited it to like an hour and a
half which is hard when you wake Jenna
from a nap it's not easy well that's why
I don't nap because I know I don't want
to wake up from a nap yeah well I fought
through it I was like I don't care if
you're mad at me you're waking up or
else we're gonna be all miss Effie you
don't watch Parks and Rec but there's an
episode where Andy goes to London he
comes back and he's jet-lagged for like
a week and he won't fight the jet lag he
just sleeps all day he wakes up like oh
yeah and then he's like a mess at work
worse that's what we did when we went to
Ireland we sort of did that we were like
sleeping when we were tired so we were
like super [ __ ] up like when we were
in Ireland and then we got back from
Ireland it takes a little while to
adjust yeah but that like you know
14-hour flight
it is a lot for your body to handle
regardless of how much you're trying to
force yourself to adjust to it
it's a lot hundred percent and when we
got to Australia it was the same deal
like we had get we got there at the
morning right so we tried to stop you
know sleep on the plane to adjust
ourselves and when you get there you're
looking excited you're like oh no I'm
good like I feeling good and then like
three hours passes and I'm not [ __ ] it's
like 10:00 a.m. and I'm exhausted yeah
and we've already like seen everything
around the house we've explored a lot do
you do now yeah but the trip overall
went really great I thought yeah we went
to fan fest and I it was a was a great
time good event they're always so great
fan fest has been some of the best
events I've ever been to yeah and I mean
as of now there you know officially
partnered in some capacity with YouTube
YouTube backs their events you know used
to be it used to just be Tony and Jay
it's
I have seen that progression like they
used to just be this international kind
of event that they would bring all over
Europe and wherever and no Asia Asia not
Europe and and they did such a good job
which I thought they always did a good
job but they would progressively get so
much better that YouTube is just like
you know what I'm gonna you know let's
back these guys let's make this a real
event or let's put our money where our
mouth is which is really cool to see
like those guys work hard and they they
treat you and treat us very well well
yeah it makes it it makes it great for
us when we go there we know that we're
we're going to be safe they're gonna put
on a good event the kids are going to be
safe like they don't make people wait in
those crazy lines where the kids can't
go to the bathroom or go get food or get
water like there the tickets are
pre-sold so nobody has to like camp out
or do anything crazy
yeah cuz we've had some events in the
past where you know somebody just didn't
put a lot of thought into how this is
actually gonna work yeah and like a
voice like VidCon is doing very well
like a just sing to people because it
used to just be like the first time that
I went to like playlist I was just
standing around and then it just turns
into a mean greed because there's no way
I had no plan yeah they had no plan
there was no like formal way to do that
yeah for sure there is now but it's much
better and I was always like dude if
[ __ ] Disneyland can figure out how
like they never even know how many
people are gonna come like somehow every
single day they stand in line for hours
and hours but they do they figure it out
I did it with fast passes like this it
should be like a VidCon or like a
YouTube FanFest like Fast Pass like come
here at X time and then you know
whatever 100% but um it was really great
and thank you to everyone that came out
and you know came and hugged me and
lucky those of you that got to hug Troye
Sivan or Connor Franta Oh JA yes jealous
I got to hug them too
I got diagonally trim that was pretty
fun oh my god Julian was trying to keep
it together for those of you that don't
know who that is your that I don't even
know what you're doing her YouTube
channel is called commune YouTube
channel and she pushes oh I'm Gigi but
like you did her humor her humor is like
there there's no one else who may
humor like that Eric she's so hysterical
and she's like I wouldn't even say
deadpan she's just so [ __ ] real yeah
like she's just such a person when she
does her humor when she does her videos
that you're like like she holds it
together so well but she's so insanely
funny yeah and she's like absolutely
beautiful in person
beautiful so nice so sweet ready her
husband right mhm yeah Rowan almost so
so nice both of them such amazing people
and she made us what were those things
called lamingtons lemming tonigh think
that's what they're called is it a
lemming dude the thing is a Livington
though because that's what she does
she's like a business where she makes us
ourselves one of her things and uh she
was like yeah but I also have
gluten-free ones and I'm like are you
real yeah oh my god it was really really
trying to keep it together yeah because
he was fangirling a lot mm-hmm yeah I
was fangirling that was cool and I got
to meet Connor you already met Connie
new Connor
yeah I know Connor it was Carmen's
birthday the other day happy birthday
Connor over the Connor and
guys-guys-guys-guys gives whose
birthdays yeah really birthday thanks
I'm gonna be 29 I'm so excited for you
very weird Ames Jenna I I said you know
what do you want to do for your birthday
like lay it on me this is like two weeks
ago I was like Jenna anything you want
to do we're doing it she was like
nothing yeah I want to do nothing and I
was like wait what do you mean why do
nothing yeah I want I want to do nothing
I want to sit on the couch with the dogs
I want to play all the squirrels I want
to eat veggie Gro I'm gonna do nothing
yeah I want to do nothing for my
birthday so against all my intuitions to
put on some crazy thing we're gonna do
nothing tomorrow
yay Thank You Julian I don't remember
you were like let's go out to dinner
let's do this in my harness this weekend
like going on this weekend we may have a
little festive time with friends and
going out whatever but that's this week
I'm not opposed to something on the
weekend if it involves alcohol alcohol
will be involved not responsibly friends
because alcoholism is terrible it's not
just alcohol its birthday alcohol yeah
um so that's good your birthday's
tomorrow that's accessible drinking for
my birthday
someone said you'll do something sneaky
on periscope you guys know me too well
but I'm really not
and I have a gift for her tomorrow that
she doesn't know about oh I'm just
kidding
but no I'm not kidding about never mind
moving on I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
take her out of the house I mean I might
bring her some stuff and whatever I'm
gonna leave I want to stay in my pajamas
all day for my birthday it's gonna be
the best guys I don't mean I think what
do I do here
no but it should be fun and I'm excited
and you know it it is kind of coming in
the middle of a crazy time for us like
in terms of our schedule
well the hills of a big trip with before
a big awards show and another trip so
it's like even if we really did want do
something huge we couldn't really pull
it off right now ya know but that was
like why we sort of planned it like this
so that for my birthday we could you
know because we've been traveling a lot
we were just at Duke and then we are in
Australia so that you know like we could
have like a pseudo weekend on a Tuesday
that's my birthday
exactly we're talking to Rome about it
like I feel like everybody regardless of
your job should get there the day off
for their birthday hundred percent yeah
it should be a given I don't understand
my jobs don't do all right I mean if you
but if you work for Dunder Mifflin
Alisha have like an epic like party with
me thrown by the party planning
committee is this the podcast where you
try and see how many references that you
can make to the office or Parks and Rec
I thought that was everybody that's what
it feels like I appreciate it oops sorry
um I feel like everyone should get their
their birthday off from work
yeah that that should happen right how
do we make that a thing
I don't know let's get Obama and
Michelle's arms down here and we'll talk
to them
let's get Deez Nuts to like make his
voice sure birthdays all officials
campaign slogan is everybody gets their
birthday off so good um someone just
said on periscope vlog your birthday
she's not to vlog I'll vlog it for her
ha log a burger she has what to watch
that in my vlog
yeah cuz I'm not gonna be doing anything
so there's nothing to vlog I'm literally
just gonna be laying down cooing at the
dogs so if you want to vlog that you can
what why why do you make that face make
any face you made a sneaky hotter face I
love this it's a recipe of our old pod
other foods doesn't many of our podcast
is like a shot to [ __ ] it's really nice
to just sit in chat because well for a
little while you know it every single
week you do need to have topics you talk
about but it's good to use every once in
a while
ya know it feels good especially since
we're so wiped but Duke University was
awesome but it was great too was
wonderful that campus is like [ __ ]
really cool ridiculous really cool it's
really awesome as an adult as someone
that went I you know I went to two
schools but they're right near each
other
Boston University had a little bit more
of a campus than Suffolk did but it's
really cool as an adult to visit other
colleges to see other people's
experiences you know like we worked at
Boston College we used to make hot dogs
to raise money for softball yeah and we
had to work so many games and we would
see they're like big campus and like
their student housing and I was like ah
dude this is [ __ ] rad like I wish I
had that experience but I'm really glad
I didn't I liked mine but it was like
crazy to go to a school like Duke that
is so you know [ __ ] it was
world-renowned and I'll II went to one
school and for good reason it's
beautiful oh yeah yeah um and but I did
do a lot of visiting of colleges like
not a ride and go on like huge trips but
I did visit my fair share of schools and
it was cool to be like that school I
mean like wow this is like this is I
remember this you know like going to
look at schools and one of the girls who
was you know on the committee that was
helping us she had just recently she was
like a sophomore or something and she
was telling us a story about she got
accepted and it's just like brought me
back you know like it was cool though
and and uh you know everyone we met was
very nice the event was really cool like
you in that giant theatre was really
cool yeah dude they were [ __ ]
cracking me up though because colleges
are cool to go and talk at because you
never really know what the audience
wants to hear yeah so I'll get a mixed
bag of like questions when we open it up
to audience questions and stuff you
never know you never know how weird it's
gonna get yeah but like some of those no
one is ever asked yeah some was like
just this girl was like can you tell us
about your worst sexual experience I'm
like oh my god yeah
and that and that's another thing like
you you hated you love it but you
appreciate him no filter
I appreciate the realness just yeah yeah
just I mean they're like they're
college-age kids they're just becoming
adults right now yeah it was awesome um
I never had the grades or scores to get
into Duke I don't think yeah I don't
know though I didn't apply I only
applied to Safe Schools because I just
wanted to live in a city yeah I applied
to a fair amount of schools I mean if
any of you are applying to colleges
right now you're probably doing it on a
website yeah for your website needs you
should check out Squarespace comm
Squarespace arqon's has some of the best
templates and the sweetest looking
professional crisp looking websites you
can have and they're very easy to run
like that's the thing about Squarespace
they look like the whole team's behind
it which it is it's squarespace's team
but it you have little to no work to do
you setup your your your look you pick a
template you pick your you know your
vibe of what you want a website to be
you pick all the features and you
customize all the links and everything
that goes on and in the website and
Squarespace does everything else so and
yeah it's great because you know you
have a problem anytime you have 24/7
customer support on Squarespace chat
with a representative so day or night
you're having an issue you reach out to
them and they will fix that issue and if
you do have a Squarespace website
honestly tweet it at us like say hey you
know here's my square so if it comes
I'll [ __ ] check that [ __ ] out like I
want to see websites I love looking at
cool like and that's another thing it
this I have a a motto in my life and it
applies to t-shirts and it applies to
websites I will go to your website and I
will wear your t-shirt if it's
comfortable and cool to look at
like if someone gives me a t-shirt is
super comfortable I don't care what it
says I'm gonna wear it that's a truly
website sure this is looking gangster I
do and I hate that term my mom gave it
to me but it's the most comfortable
shirt and if a website looks really cool
looks really sexy I don't care if
they're selling like grass I got a
little crush off the [ __ ] lawn I want
to look at website so check it out
Squarespace com enter product code JJ
for Jenna and Julian and you get 10% off
your website and thank you Squarespace
as always for your continued support of
the gym Julian
caste and speaking of the 24-hour
customer service when I was in Australia
this is now the second time this has
happened to me I'm not like okay so I'm
a little bit lazy sometimes when road
goes to Squarespace to make a website
about grass I'm a little lazy sometimes
when it comes to only using my phone
internationally when I can connect to
Wi-Fi because I'll really care why
you're pretty rough about not like I
will pay extra money to be on the
Internet and to use my phone overseas
because it's you know part of my job you
know to not be disconnected from the
world yeah so I'm like you know what if
it goes over it is what it is I'm gonna
pay it anyways regardless of if I pay
for it upfront or if I pay for it
in hindsight um and my data got shut off
in Australia I get a notification on my
phone it got shot off in Toronto in the
same way xed yeah I get a text we're at
a bar on our last day wearing manly it
was really manly Beach fast and [ __ ]
heaven on earth I didn't text from I
don't mean to drag this company but ATT
is my phone service provider
Greg Greg cuz they're great otherwise I
think I don't know man I just use my
phone I get a text and they're like your
data has been shut off like there was no
warning there's no like there would you
like to keep it going and they just shut
it off so it goes in the text says call
this number if you would like to you
know have it turned back on I call the
number from Australia it's like 4:00 in
the afternoon so in the middle of the
night I think or something I whatever
the [ __ ] put it outside of their
business hours oh yeah call and they're
like please call back during business
hours I'm like you [ __ ] you can
shut off my data and shut off my phone
and when I call you to try and fix it
you tell me to [ __ ] call you back
how [ __ ] how happy where we're having
where
okay having an international helpline
only open door sir during certain
business hours is like having a vampire
shop that's only open during the day
like it's the most [ __ ] stupid thing
you could do I'm sorry international
you're like my international line it's
always in the middle of the night oh my
god always somewhere I said why are you
gonna ever close you have to have a
24-hour support I can do it you can do
it you can do it too
I just like it was the most nonsensical
thing ever it like oh do do oh your
phone your phone's data shut off please
call us if you'd like to turn it back on
call them we're sorry call back a better
time [ __ ] off [ __ ] you but we got to
turn back on the next day the next day
but then we were getting on a plane so I
can't music man another thing about 18
not to drag but another thing about 18 T
which bug me is like we were we were
traveling and I was like I called them
and I was like I'm going to Australia
I'd like to throw a lot of my money at
you so I can be on Twitter in another
country yeah and so they're like okay
here's our gold package it's 800
megabytes for like whatever and I was
like okay I'd like the next one please
because I'll go through that in an hour
right and they're like no that's it
like that's the highest you can get and
then you have to pay over dues so
basically it's set up for you to already
go over right I was like I don't mean to
drag AT&T because I know it's a lot more
sense like another bond like that
they're all just sort of criminal when
it comes to you being able to use your
phone in another country guys you're
making this drag here hey if you guys
have anything in the commentary I'm not
even joking to help us please because in
the comments if you know of a provider
like I've heard good things
Jenna doesn't think t-mobile's getting
their act together I've heard that they
are I've heard that the game we're
getting our act together with their
coverage and spreading coverage and
having fair deals where you can get new
phones every year and pay fair monthlies
and data I've heard good things it was
on the reddit the other day which is
something I value as a proper source
tell us in the comments if you know of
any provider that's not [ __ ] not saying
HD is [ __ ] but some things that they do
can be do do like yeah my phone is about
to die for all you guys on periscope
percent life on the edge it was
literally 20% like five minutes ago yet
just so you know if the
that's the periscope just like says
peace that's why it's cuz uh my phone
died oh okay
it'll meet that our IP and peace my
phone um was I just gonna say oh the
other thing that sucks is that you
looked in because we travel a like fair
enough like a fair amount enough for us
to have seriously looked into other
forms of Wi-Fi likes hotspots and that
sort of thing and Julien was so excited
he did research for like a year I don't
know I just waited around was a lot of
looking and waiting around he was
waiting for this one called karma I
think and he was so excited he finally
got it like this was look because we've
waited especially Australia forgot yeah
Bali
like we've we've had to upload you know
for an entire day like that's how slow
the internet is you can't do anything
about it and sometimes it'll like stop
or it'll get shut off and then you just
start over and there's just no way to
fix it especially like in Bali or
whenever I was in Mumbai oh my god
count I remember really was just in
tears in Mumbai like it I feel terrible
just this is never gonna come out this
videos just gonna disappear so he did
all this research he got this hot spot
we get it to Australia and I have 10
gigs of data ready to go and data ready
to go and they're not available outside
the US like come on man it was like it
was all it was all the hours I've spent
waiting and trying to order that thing
came down to that one moment where I was
like it's finally here this moment I
would knew it was coming where we needed
Wi-Fi and no one had it yeah and I
brought some hmm and then it didn't work
it was terrible I was really sad yeah
I'm really upset I was pretty bummed I
mean cuz the not only was I waiting and
looking around for the right hot spot
for a while because it isn't the fastest
but it's got really good reviews and I
read a lot into it the only thing is
that like I ordered in December it had
like an eight month production halt on
the [ __ ] on producing and shipping
out these products I think it was a
Kickstarter at one point which is when I
initially ordered it something like that
and we were expected to get in like
December Jan
and there was an 8-month production halt
because of some [ __ ] production issue
that we finally got him in like what
July late July yeah um but yeah maybe so
you know when we're at someplace in the
US or maybe some day when they expand to
global coverage all I'll have that
moment but I didn't get my juicy moment
and all I want is one [ __ ]
juicy moment I know well what I've done
in the past you've seen me do it I'll
take my phone I'll turn on a hot spot
and you know try and upload something
and see which is slower like the Wi-Fi
wherever is my favorite thing is that
we're bright when you got the text that
your data was turned off you try to turn
on the hot spot like where are you gonna
get this chance for money I will try
anything to get it's the worst like my
phone always gets shut off not yours not
Rome's and then you guys just sit there
on your phone and I just stare at the
sky like I have nothing to [ __ ] I
know beautiful though in life like
that's not a bad look scary but even
like when I did when I drove across the
country to move to Los Angeles I was in
the middle of the Badlands like to
anyone that's like well why don't you go
to a coffee shop or a library and get
better Wi-Fi likes I'm telling you some
of these places it doesn't there's
there's there is no option you have no
option crazy
yeah um but yeah I mean I will just do
the best that I can and sometimes the
answer is that like you either get no
internet or you get really really really
really slow internet but what's worse I
don't I don't think I don't think no
Internet's worse I think slow slow slow
internet is worse because it gives you a
glimmer of hope it does and then it
crashes down on your world like when I
was a kid after school I would come home
and we had dial-up internet so we were
only allowed to use it so much because
it plugged into the phone line so no one
could call the house didn't be on the
computer if someone was expecting a call
right exactly yeah so I would get um I
would go to this website I can't
remember the name of it but it was just
like you know nothing like there's
nothing there it was just full with like
purple gems and [ __ ] and you just like
go there and scroll down the page and
look at them that's it like cartoons
yeah like it's nothing
and I would just sit there and like wait
and wait and wait and wait and by the
time my internet time was up you know
like an hour whatever in the kitchen
timer you know it had loaded just like a
picture of like a girl and I was like
all right this is a good day because
that's what I got and because then you
could be on instant messenger the whole
time and at least that was worth it
when you hear the like of your crush
leaving because they don't want to talk
to you either I would never have laughs
I would have talked to you it's an art
it wouldn't it would be super creepy
don't be like a lot you hold you like a
kid and yes - school creeper I was a kid
I would have been 12 and you would have
been stick and I would have been the
coolest kid in my first-grade class no
let's not ever think about that ever did
you just what do use goals to that goal
no sixth grade
well what a babies that you babysat
Julian ill you're 12 okay it's okay
we're just hanging out no one said
anything Jesus this conversation yeah
that's so totally weird if you make it
weird and I made aware you did made it
weird
well sure what was your favorite part of
Australia hmm well 100% manly beach hmm
oh okay my favorite part of Australia
all together um well first let me
preface it with this every time I go to
Australia I feel so lucky because
there's gluten-free food everywhere yeah
like everywhere they are so far ahead of
where we are in the United States of the
availability and the accommodations of
gluten free food and the awareness of
celiac and actually like yeah actually
yeah every waiter asked if I'd sillier
like basically at a stupid coffee shop
they would know and have gluten-free
bread so that's a preface and the coffee
amazing preface then my favorite real
part this time was manly beach and on
top of that was moonshines bar in Manly
Beach we had such an insane day just
walking around it was like so perfect
the weather was great it was like packed
with people but we even care like it was
just so fun we ate great food at that it
was at papi papi churro papi papi chulo
- papi chulo was
we launched at papi chulo on manly beach
and had amazing food had drinks at
moonshines
and there was a rugby function at
moonshines and one of the guys who tell
them why you like moonshine so much okay
so I went there original I been wanting
to go sorry those Julianne unplugged my
headphone I didn't do it now I'm in a
vacuum
oh is your are your headphones like
dying yeah probably should we just take
them off yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] more oval more get [ __ ] more
tonight I've been watching Geordie Shore
sorry but so we what okay so I was on
Twitter and anytime like we go to a
place you guys are so so [ __ ] cool on
Twitter like go to this place giving me
all sorts of recommendations so thank
you for always doing that but someone
said go to moon shines on manly Beach
they have a bunch of ciders on tap and
it's cheap at like cheap ass and I was
like star I'm gonna start this tweet and
I'm also going to screenshot it because
I start a lot of tweets and I might
forget where it is so I screenshot it
and it kind of left my brain and then
when we were talking about what we
should do on our day off Rome was like
well where should we go should go to the
beach I was like well someone tweeted
that there's this really cool bar with a
lot of cider but I forget where it is
and she was like well is it Bondi or I
was like no and she was like is it manly
I was like yeah and she was like let's
go to manly I was like okay and we go to
manly just not knowing anything because
Rome is the only one who's been there
yeah we took a ferry took a ferry to
manly most beautiful ferry ride ever
awesome and we just had the day of our
life and we get to moonshines and
there's [ __ ] sick amounts of cider
some of the best tasting cider I've ever
had if you ever get cider and town ever
gets hit on tap in the u.s. is called
the hills cider it's my new favorite
I'll never be able to drink it again
till I'm in Australia probably but they
had cider but then there was a rugby
function and this guy named Dan came up
and recognized us and said hi and he was
very sweet and he bought us a couple of
beers or ciders and and then he was he
was just like hanging out with us and he
was so again he was this giant Ozzy
[ __ ] rug - dude he was so nice
was nice it was just one of the
experiences where it was like a weirdly
perfect day yeah I thought something
terrible was gonna happen is like no one
can have a day this guy you know I was
like let's go to sleep from bad yeah we
keep enjoying ourselves something bad is
gonna happen it was really really
awesome that was my favorite part
yeah and like a the geography of a kind
of like hurt my brain a little bit so I
was like all right so we take a ferry
there but then we can take the cab back
yeah in the cab ride is shorter than the
ferry ride like it was a little bit of a
mindfuck like where exactly we were yeah
but it was [ __ ] awesome beautiful
well because this was our third time in
Australia so you know the first two
times we sort of did the tourist stuff
like you see the things you need to see
a lot more how that right and it's also
really stressful like every time I go
somewhere I assume it's the last time
I'm ever gonna be there course yeah so
like you want to see everything that you
need to see before you leave yeah so
like the first time we were there I was
like I want you know I really want to
see the Opera House and like yeah in
darling harbour and all of that and
you're like stressed out that you're not
gonna see it all and then we went back
there again and this is our third time
so this time we finally got to like not
be stressed about sightseeing and also
go to a place that you know you wouldn't
usually go to unless you had a week or
more in Australia that's a really
incredible point you know like we've
gotten so lucky to have gone there
before so that we didn't have to like
make it to everywhere we're just kind of
relaxing it's really girl you want to do
but yeah like travel when they're like
alright guys now you gotta go do this
and do that you got to see this is not
and half of them you're like I could
have lived that yeah are you doing it's
like honoring a trip you did not do but
overall is great trip and I'm happy to
be back
we're happy to see your dog's like we
miss them a lot that was that's probably
one of the hardest things for us when we
travel just missing the dogs yeah I just
I love Jenna not legging flying and
everything
I don't really like flying and I don't
really like staying up high we stayed up
like pretty high and the balcony makes
me nervous because I kept saying to me
I'm not a bird Julie and I'm not a bird
wiry up this high and I'm like well you
got I got a point I don't know why rebel
cuz I was just so I don't like being on
a balcony like in Singapore I was on a
huge [ __ ] balcony like that and sort
of just like you know chest high and
you're like dude like what if [ __ ]
anything happened like you just fall out
like I'm just I have this very
irrational fear of like falling out of
your pal knie you know what I mean yeah
so I'll sit on the ground and on the
balcony and like try and enjoy it a
little bit then like at night I was like
closing all the curtains like not a bird
Julian why would I want to live up this
high she's not a bird but we did we got
to see some fireworks that was pretty
cool that was cool
oh I'm putting a vlog out tomorrow
morning and it has the manly beach trip
yeah it has all that fun stuff we're
talking about so you'll be able to see
that but yes overall a great trip yeah
at the one thing that never like fails
to like blow my mind when we're in
Australia is like you'll go to a cafe in
the middle of the mall first of all the
cafe is like teeny tiny like as big as a
closet but that's it yeah the seating is
like in the center of the mall like
aisle basically so traffic people
walking goes on either side of you and
then you're just sitting in the middle
of the mall and like you could think
you're just eating a cafe but they'll
serve you the most beautiful breakfast
you could ever imagine like they take
their breakfast show seriously dude I
got a Benedict eggs benedict that was
brighter than my future and I ate it and
I was look like I'm in Reno Nate I was
like in the middle of them all what am i
doing I know and it was amazing our guru
bread of course like right yeah you're
right it's every like there's those
cafes everywhere and they're all so good
they take their brekkie seriously they
didn't come in [ __ ] spiders they came
there to eat Brecon get more eat branch
get more okay I just want to tell you
Julian and Rome were both watching
Geordie Shore which I haven't watched
yet for those of you that don't know UK
version of Jersey yeah exactly
except they show like titties and oh
it's funky and like they show titties
everything so they're like the two of
them are trying to watch it at the same
time and like just making sure there's
no like kids around them cuz yeah
graphics like titties out titties out
and like you know in Jersey Shore like
at night when they show that the room
cams like in the black and white or
whatever and no cutaway no cutaway they
don't [ __ ] go to you see them [ __ ]
in the bed like under the covers you
don't see it but you did happen and it's
on camera
it's just they they like to say instead
of getting drunk they say they get
pissed or they say they get more like
mortal more like mortal let's get more
well cuz my grace to them they were both
saying it they wouldn't stop saying oh
good get more I'm like what the [ __ ] you
guys saying first of all what are you
talking about
second of all what the [ __ ] are you
saying more young mortal like it means
really like super wasted I don't think I
would ever want to be more you would
want to be more it's like Mortal Kombat
like I don't out that sounds way to say
you're me okay it's Friday time to get
more know what about what about just
like a few drinks
no but you think yeah so it's the same
thing it's just called more just like
have some nice calm fun not like some
more old fun I don't want to have more
fun again it sounds violent I'll have
more it's not scary more oh no no thank
you
no it's the best some ones we let me
today oh I'm so happy you watched
Geordie Shore hashtag mortal I was like
yes well more yeah I've been watching
yeah I really won't watch it but I have
been following I think a couple of them
on Instagram for years oh [ __ ] I gotta
follow them on Instagram
yeah like Charlotte Charlotte's really
funny her hair made me [ __ ] laugh out
loud just that one shot of where there
is
she's got like these like giant pigtails
like I just dunno she's coming out of
her yes honey she's like one of the
funnier people in the show cuz she
they're I mean they're all I mean
they're all like pretty goofy and like
they all get wasted all the time but
some of them are like pretty pretty
funny mole yeah um I need to download
the rest of the episodes cuz I didn't
get to watch the whole season oh I'm
sorry
I was watching party down south but not
on this trip on the last rabbit ray but
I didn't make it all the way through me
to get our reality TV dicks in order I
know um they're really good shows
because you get so invested in the
people yeah and it's so dumb you're like
you're like I miss like being there when
they all go out on Friday nights and
getting more I miss watching it it's
like another your friends yeah except
they don't know you it's like what the
internet site like whenever I meet a
youtuber for the first time I'm sort of
like huh oh that's how felon has no oh I
watch you and uh sorry sorry for spying
on is
nice to meet you there's to me like I
met Lauren Curtis for the first time she
was majestic and like we are sitting in
the car on the way home and I said you
know the most awkward thing ever I'm
like dude I watch the video of your
teeth she she got like Lumineers like
they look beautiful and I was like dude
I'll watch the video of your teeth like
they look so great like that's amazing I
would love to get that done and she's
like she just started dying laughing
because in hindsight I realized as soon
as it left my mouth just how [ __ ]
weird that is to say to someone you know
must him or say something like that
well it's like it's happening me before
when I'm like I'm telling someone what
I've watched of them yeah and I'm like
oh my god I'm so [ __ ] embarrassing
right now but it's not nursing it's cute
okay I watch your snapchats and like
just you know [ __ ] look I said that
about Grace's dog the other day I'm like
I will get goose every single day never
met goose but I look at goose every day
know it's a weird feel it is it is cuz
when you do it you don't realize they
don't know you're doing it but your mole
you're more like emo
um you guys [ __ ] survived you a real
MVP periscope is still going there's
enough still here um but this I like
this podcasters good puck yeah this is
fun uh Thank You Squarespace again for
sponsoring the podcast for all of your
website needs and also your really sexy
and easy to do website needs go to
Squarespace calm and check it out
seriously you can do a free trial but if
you decide to go with it you get 10% off
if you use product code JJ checkout and
if you ever do use Squarespace please
tweet us your website so yeah love to
see them someone just make more old
cupcakes more and it's just like you
know really exciting themed cupcakes um
everyone tweet and comment happy
birthday to my lovely girlfriend and uh
we will see you guys next week for ya
and thank you for letting us do one of
those good podcast this week if you
really find that interesting in the
chain of events lately we kind of just
needed to chill out yeah for a little
bit remember like for sure why we're
doing it you know always always we're
gonna go get more it's not all we're
gonna go eat dinner tonight we're gonna
go eat dinner is that a plot you you get
more all about dinner
I get more all about food period I think
I like inhaled my Triple A today Julian
turns into a Julian tornado and just
inhales it like the Tasmanian Devil want
you to go that's what I do except the
foods there when I start and then it's
gone when I'm done that's right well
guys go get me we'll see you next week
bye guys